People aren't taught that comparing what
we have to.
They're hypothetical politically,
politically,
ideologically motivated.
Utopia is actually a bad idea,
you know,
because it's,
it just isn't difficult to take a look
at a system like our system and say,
well,
look at all the problems that has
compared to a hypothetical system that
doesn't have any problems at all.
And it's like,
well,
yeah man,
there's problems,
there's,
you know,
we've,
we've taken like 99 percent of the fish
out of the ocean and,
and you know,
the degree to which our current level of
economic activity is truly sustainable
without alteration is at least
debatable.
Even though I don't think it's nearly as
terrible as people make out,
make it out to be.
But I don't think it's disputable that
our current socioeconomic structures are
the most productive and the most free
structures that have ever been produced
by people anywhere in the world.
And one of the things you can say about
capitalism and free enterprise and and
the western stress on individuality is
that even though it does produce
inequality,
a all systems producing inequality and
and without any real distinction between
the right and the left by the wayside
because I'm so new book called the Great
Leveler by Walter Shadelle,
who I'm going to be talking to later
this month,
he did an analysis,
empirical analysis trying to figure out
if you,
if you grouped governments by right wing
philosophy say or by left wing
philosophy and then you calculated
inequality coefficient.
Would that left wing organizations be
characterized by reduced inequality?
And the answer was no.
There's no evidence that they are.
And what that points to,
and this is something very fundamental,
it's a far more fundamental than than
political,
is that inequality is the rule in
cooperative slash competitive
organizations.
You can't positive value without
producing a hierarchy,
right?
Because you paused,
it devalues,
say this is worth doing.
And everyone says,
yeah,
this is worth doing well.
Then what happens automatically is that
it turns out that some people are better
at doing it than other people,
no matter what it is,
and then they'll get better and better
at it,
like the Credo principle you're talking
about too,
and then they start getting better at
it.
So the problem is is that without you
with if you're going to positive value,
which you have to do,
if you're going to act and immediately
you create a hierarchy and you also
build into the value claim,
the claim that a is better than b.
You also built into that the idea that
if a is better than B,
than people who are doing better at a
should be differentially rewarded
compared to people who who aren't.
There's no way around that if you're
going to play the game and so you're
stuck with inequality,
but there isn't any evidence that that
social engineering policies are really
very good at dispensing with inequality,
which is a fundamental political problem
and no one really knows what to do about
it,
but criticizing the entire society.
I mean,
the thing about the west,
and this is increasingly true all over
the world,
is that it's generating our approach
generates a tremendous amount of wealth
for ever.
I mean,
it even happened in China,
you know,
despite their exceptionally totalitarian
leanings.
And so what happens with the lefties is
that they say,
well,
inequality as a consequence of the west
and the consequences of capitalism,
which is palpably false claim and say,
well,
because it produces inequality,
then it's a corrupt system.
It's like,
no,
every system produces inequality,
but hardly any also produce wealth.